ثلاث صناعات في الاردن وراء تعزيز قدرتها
التنافسيه في الاسواق الخارجيه غير ان هذا
المسعى يصطدم بلاهيب اسعار الطاقه
المتساعده ورغم ان الاردن يتصدر دول
المنطقه العربيه من حيث التوسع في استخدام
الطاقه المتجدده بنسبه 30% من اجمالا تاجه
من الكهرباء فان هذه المصانع بمنطقه
الموقر شرقيا البلاد التي تزود اسواقا
عربيه عده بمنتجاتها لا تحصل على ما تحتاج
اليه من الطاقه طلبت ادارته هذا الاستثمار
العربي اتاحه المجال لها لانتاج طاقه
متجدده ولم يسمح لها سواء ست سماء طلبه
بتقدم الدراسه كامله بس للاسف ترفض نهائيا
القطاع الصناعي اهم القطاعات وبدون دعم
القطاع الصناعي في الطاقه ما له نجاح
نهائيا يعني كل المصنع يسكر ويصف على
اليمين يقولوا مستثمرون ان دول مجاوره
تدعم الصناعات فيها فعلا لا قولا في حين
زادت الحكومه الاردنيه اسعار المشتقات
النفطيه 6 10 مره في بطون عامين الصعود
المستمر لاسعار المشتقات النفطيه يقابله
تراجع في تنافسيه الصناعات واستوطلبات لا
تتوقف بان تسمح الحكومه الصناعيين بالحصول
على طاقه المتجدده وفقا لحاجه خطوه
الانتاج في المقابل لدى الحكومه طموح لرفع
قدره توليد الكهرباء من الطاقه المتجدده
الى 50% بحلول عام 2030 كما تسعى الى
تخزين الطاقه الكهربائيه في سد الموجب
وذلك لانهاء شكاوى الصناعيين والمستثمرين
المستمره في قرار مجلس الوزراء
لتاحه المجال للاستثمارات الجديده او
توسعه الاستثمارات القائمه للحصول على
مشاريع اكبر من واحد على الشبكه وجاريهم
فيها حاليا همم يعني ان شاء الله هاي راح
تحفظ من شكوى
[موسيقى]
ويبدو ان ملف الطاقه يثير قلق الحكومه
والمستثمر والمواطن على حد سواء
[موسيقى]
الطرف ان تدعم المحروقات ويظل اكبر تحدي
يواجه الاردن كيفيه توفير وحدات تخزين
اضافيه من اجل الانتاج والاستثمار لا سيما
مع الخطه الطموحه للمملكه بان تصبح مركزا
لتصدير الطاقه الخضراء الى دول الجوار حسن
الشوبكي على الجزيره الموقر شرق العاصمه
الاردنيه